les humains viennent s'installer ici
pour y vivre notre territoire est
vulnérable et notre devoir est de le
protéger
vous avez une des figures et l'article
c'est une bonne chose au fond dans
l'arctique jeu pourrait construire des
immeubles des centres commerciaux je
vais être riche non il faut que tu te
rendes à new york
j'aurai besoin de renfort musclée sur le
terrain tous les petits gars il veut que
tu décris s'il veut te montrer combien
il est résistant à temps vous êtes
invincible
j'en ai vraiment pas fait pour ce genre
de mission
je sais exactement refuge ou non je veux
me sauver l'arctique
ces beaux projets ça va chauffer
mes meilleurs copains
prenez l'hélicoptère est trouvée bois
ces deux ans panier